national border patrol council president
brandon judd brandon
a lot to get into uh first though this
report from cbp uh on the agents being
cleared of quote whipping migrants and
just to remind the audience and bill
alluded to it
at the time president biden said it was
uh it was horrible to see to treat
people like they did horses nearly
running them over
people being strapped it's outrageous i
promise you those people will pay
at the time even the photographer said
that wasn't true but that was the
narrative the white house went with
yeah charles and people can make
mistakes even president biden can make
mistakes and it can be excusable if he
comes back and he clarifies that mistake
if he would have come back and he would
have apologized to those agents
for making a false accusation before all
the evidence was out that would be one
thing but this president refuses to take
any responsibility for anything that he
does including false statements that
ruin agents careers these agents have
been on administrative duty for the past
10 months their careers are basically
over and they were ruined because the
president of the united states failed to
let an investigation take place he
failed to listen to all the evidence he
only pandered to open border activists
and that's why these agents are now
suffering yeah you know brandon also i
got to be honest with you it hurt me
as a black man because every time
president biden opens his mouth he's
telling black americans that no one
likes you that you're under threat that
government officials are out to harm you
and hurt you if you're a little black
kid watching tv and you listen to the
president you think these people are
chasing you down and hitting you with
the whip and you know they deliberately
do this uh it's much more than the
border they deliberately stoke fear and
they divide us as a nation and it's the
absolute most despicable thing possible
for the person in the white house to do
so do you expect an apology
no no he's not going to apologize and
what makes it very difficult about that
it makes it nearly impossible for me and
my fellow agents to put on uniforms and
go out and do the job we know that we're
going to be scrutinized we know that we
have that target on our back we know
that anything that we do that the
president doesn't like we're going to be
in trouble for these people that did the
investigation they are executive branch
employees they fall directly under the
president the president ruined those
three agents
my three agents lives that he ruined
those agents lives he could have ruined
the investigators lives if they didn't
find that they did something wrong when
you listen to commissioner magnus say
that he has confidence in the
investigation of course he's going to
say that he's a political appointee if
he wouldn't say that the president could
remove him the president could have
ensured that those opr investigators if
they didn't find some sort of wrongdoing
he could ensure that their their careers
would have been ruined as well i got
less than a minute ago but let me ask
you before i let you go about the
governor abbott's order uh this new new
order to to return migrants
how's that working out do you do you
think that's a right move
it is the right move it's up to the
governor to decide what he can do under
his authority the courts have to step in
and tell him that he can't but he has to
develop a plan
and program first and decide for himself
whether or not it's legal i'm glad that
he's stepping up i'm glad that he's
doing what is necessary to secure the
border that the white house isn't doing
good for him
brandon a lot of folks though do
appreciate the work you and your men do
you should know that thank you very much
appreciate it hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now